الى طهران التي قالت ان هناك تقدما جيدا
في مفاوضات الملف النووي وانها تتبادل
رسائل مع واشنطن تزامنا مع هذا الموقف
كشفت طهران عن صاروخ باليسيا جديد من جانب
اخر الجيش الاسرائيلي قال انه اسقط مسيره
اجتازت الحدود الاسرائيليه من جهه لبنان
وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد قال في وقت سابق
ان تصريحات قادته العسكريين خلال اليومين
الماضيين لا تعني انه سيشن حربا قريبا على
لبنان او مع ايران
لمزيد من التفاصيل معنى من طهران مراسل
الجزيره نور الدين دغير ومن القدس مراسلنا
الياس كرام والبدايه معك الياس كرام في
الخبر المستجد حول اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي
اولا انه اسقط طائره مسيره كانت قادمه من
جنوب لبنان
بالفعل حسن حدث ذلك قبل اقل من نصف ساعه
وهذا الاعلان جاء عن اسقاط الطائره
المسيره وهي من النوع الصغير المخصص
لعمليات التصوير في بلده زراعيه وهي
الواقعه على القطاع الاوسط للحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه واسقاط هذه المسيره
ياتي ويدلل عمليا حسن على حاله التاهب
القصوى وحاله الاستنفار واليقظه التي
تعتري الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه الايام
تحديدا بعد المناورات العسكريه الضخمه
التي اجراها حزب الله في جنوب لبنان في
الايام الماضيه صحيح بان هذه المسيره لم
تكن مسيره هجوميه ولم تكن مسيره مفخخه كما
شاهدنا بالصور التي عممها الجيش
الاسرائيلي لكنها قادره بكل تاكيد على
التصوير وعلى جمع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
عن تحصينات وتجمعات الجيش الاسرائيلي على
الحدود مع لبنان وهذا اسرائيل تنظر اليه
بخطوره بالغه لان هذه المعلومات قد تستخدم
في المستقبل ضد اسرائيل في اي عمليه او
مواجهه قد تقع في الماضي حدثت هنالك
عمليات خروج متبادله من كلا الطرفين حزب
الله تعالى ايضا مع مسيرات اسرائيليه
واسقط بعضها كما اعلم كما اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الماضي بانه اسقط مسيرات
كهذه او مسيرات تجسسيه اكبر وهجوميه في
البحر المتوسط وكذلك مسيرات اخترقت الحدود
من الجهه اللبنانيه لكن بالمجمل العام حسن
هذا يدلل على حاله التاهب القصوى الموجوده
على الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه
ومخافه التدهور الاوضاع الامنيه هناك
اليوم الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما جاء المتحدث
بلسان الجيش وقال بان اسرائيل لا يعني
تهديدات سياستها وقادتها العسكريين بانها
ماضيه في عمليه او في حرب ضد ايران او ضد
لبنان هذا يدلل على ان اسرائيل ربما خافت
حتى هي من تهديداتها وهي خافت بان هذه
التهديدات ربما تن سلبا او تفهم سلبا من
الطرف الاخر على انها تهديد مباشر او
تخطيط مبطن لدى اسرائيل بشن هجوم على
ايران او هجوم على حزب الله في لبنان هذه
التصريحات على الجانب الايراني الذي كشف
اليوم عن صاروخ باليستي
يسمى خيبر بالاضافه ايضا الى ما اعلن عن
تقدم في مفاوضات الملف النووي نور الدين
اما حسن لنبدا السياق الثاني وهو سياق
الحديث عن المفاوضات نوويه وما اعلنه وزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير عبد الله
هيان اول اولا نضع سياق هذا الحديث جاء
خلال جاء خلال اجتماع
لاعضاء الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه مع حفيد
مؤسسه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه وذلك بمناسبه
الذكرى السنويه لوفاه مؤسسه الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه روح الله على المستوى الخميني
فكان الحديث في ملفات متعدده كان احدى هذه
الملفات هو الملف النووي الايراني هنا
يتحدث وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه على ان
هناك تقدما حدث في المفاوضات ما بين ايران
وخاصه ما بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عن طريق الرسائل غير المباشره التي تنقلها
دول تلعب دور الوساطه في هذا الاتجاه اذا
هذا المعطى تتحدث عنه الخارجيه ربما
لمجموعه من الاعتبارات الاعتبار الاول قد
يكون يرتبط كذلك بطبيعه العلاقه ما بين
المفاوضات النوويه وبين علاقه ايران
بالوكاله الدوليه للطاقه ربما هل يؤشر على
ان هناك انفراجا ما وقع ما بين ايران
والوكاله الدوليه ربما قد يؤثر بشكل كبير
على التقرير الذي من المقرر ان يقدمه
المدير العام للوكاله خلال الاسبوع المقبل
وفي انعقاد يحك جلسات حكام الوكاله في
الاسبوع الاول من يونيو وكذلك في ظل
الوصفات الاقليميه هل هناك انفراج اذن نحن
الان امام روايه ايرانيه هي تصدر تصدر
المشهد فيها وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
يتحدث على ان هناك تقدم لكن بكل تاكيد
تبقى هذه الروايه تنتظر كذلك ما سيصدر عن
الروايه الامريكيه وما تقوله في هذا
الخصوص خاصه اذا ما فعلا كانت هناك خطوات
متقدمه في العمل الدبلوماسي من اجل اعاده
انجاح الاتفاقنا اذا نحن الان امام روايه
ايرانيه ربما قد قد يقرا جزء من هذه
الروايه في ظل التصعيد القائم هل يمكن
القول بان اسرائيل ربما اشتمت نوعا ما من
التقارب ما بين ايران والوكاله الدوليه او
قرب ايران من
نوع من
الخروج من ازمه توقف الاتفاق النووي
والمفاوضات النوويه ربما ليرتفع صوته
تهديدها ربما قد يكون هذا السؤال المطروح
ربما يتداوله كذلك
المحللون هنا في ايران على انه قد يكون
جزء من المناوره التي تقوم بها اسرائيل من
اجل الضغط على ايران وكذلك من اجل الضغط
على القوى المتحالفه مع اسرائيل خاصه
باتجاه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
جانب التهديدات يبدو كذلك على ان الجانب
الايراني لم يكتفي بهذا التصريح السياسي
الذي يتحدث عن فراجه ما في الاتفاق النووي
لكن يتحدث عن تهديد بطريقه ما او الرد على
التهديد الاسرائيلي بطريقه ما قد تقرا
التجربه الصاروخيه التي قامت بها ايران
اليوم كجزء من هذا الرد خاصه اذا ما اخذنا
هذه التجربه في السياق الظروف الحاليه
التي تمر بها المنطقه وتمر بها العلاقه ما
بين ايران واسرائيل وارتفاع وتيره التهديد
الاسرائيلي باتجاه طهران لو كان هذا الحدث
ربما في وقت ما غير هذا التوقيت قد يكون
الامر عادي ا باعتبار ان ايران تختبر
صواريخ على طول صواريخ متنوعه لكن الان
تختبر هذا الطرق هذا الصاروخ وتختار هذا
التوقيت بالذات يبدو انها الرساله كذلك
الى الجانب الاسرائيلي وهنا يتحدث وزير
الدفاع الايراني ليقول بان ما اعلنت ايران
اليوم وما قامت به ايران اليوم هو رساله
لمن وصفهم بالاعداء على ان ايران ستدافع
عن امنها القومي والمكسباتها القوميه اذا
لنستمع الى ما قاله وزير الدفاع الايراني
رسالتنا الى اعدائه اننا عازمون على تعزيز
قدراتنا للدفاع عن الوطن ومنجزات الثوره
الاسلاميه ونظهر الاعداء انهم لا يستطيعون
الوقوف في طريقنا نحو التقدم والتطور
ورساله هذا الانجاز لاصدقائنا انه يساهم
في تعزيز السلم والاستقرار في المنطقه
ويشكل دعما لهم وللدول التي تسير على طريق
محاربه نظام الهيمنه
شكرا لك نور الدين الدغير مراسل الجزيره
من طهران وشكرا للياس كرام الذي كان معنا
من القدس